I'm digger and I'm going for the role of
Billy
he wasn't planning on taking that body
from me were you you get away man I
found him I got dibs oh I guess I should
start running you got dibs
I earned him you came in a car that's
not fair he's mine that's not fair he's
mine well not anymore
now listen you got two choices I didn't
go quietly and I take the body or you
stay I beat the crap out of you and I
still think the way you beat the crap
out of John Brown okay chambers you
little [ __ ]
this is your last chance easy way hard
way what do you say when you go screw
your mother some more you are dead kid
you're gonna have to kill me Billy oh I
got no problem with that okay
now listen why don't you put that away
before you shoot yourself in the foot
with it okay you ain't got a sec to
shoot a woodchuck if you don't stand
still I'm gonna shoot you okay come on
muttering yes give me that gun
okay and get out of here while you still
have a chance you must have at least
some sense right so if my fat when
you're cheap dime-store hood what are
you gonna do
are you gonna kill me yeah Billy I am
maybe you will maybe you won't
oh don't you worry about that
[Music]
Jesus place is a real [ __ ]
it's okay okay okay I don't see any
waves around here do you
i I see waves of [ __ ] cow [ __ ] max I
used to cash [ __ ] I don't see any cows
well clearly you haven't seen a high
school girl yeah that's not fun
no no it's not it's not funny you know
why cuz I'm stuck here forever in this
nightmare this crazy friggin hick town
twilight zone and a [ __ ] of a mother
she's happy
what'd you say nothing you say it's my
fault it's my fault that we're here I
didn't say I'm hey hey
[Music]
[Music]
once I get mundo billion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
name's Billy
[Music]